be the commencement speaker is one of
the biggest honors in my entire life my
education here had a profound impact on
my life and coming back here reminds me
of how important CMU is taught me first
how to work hard work harder than anyone
else but also taught me some amazing
skills analytical problem-solving
mathematical kind of total holistic
approach to solving problems and that
has served me very well throughout my
career instead of plotting new student
speaker by februari and I was like okay
well that's two days from now let's
let's figure out what what needs to be
done because I I really want to do this
I don't really want to get my hall so I
told my advisor she was like dude I'm
gonna write you a recommendation I just
and I was lucky enough to be honored to
be everything that I learned here I
continue to use really literally every
day at work so I I hold my experiences
here very dear and it's wonderful to
just be given the opportunity and come
back it's always very nostalgic for me
the campus is a bit different than it
was when I was here to fight so it
reminds me of you know who that kid was
30 years ago just kind of wanted was
driving and hoping to be able to make a
career and that my
life would allow me to keep telling
stories I'm a computer scientist and
Carnegie Mellon is one of the most well
recognizing well respected institutions
in my field so the fact that I'm they
recognize me is it true